in early 2022 former Disney Bob shape
had contacted Governor Ron DeSantis to
express his concern over Florida's an
education bill that bans the teaching of
gender identity to young children
DeSantis revealed details of the
conversation in the chapter of his new
Memoir uh oh why do people write Memoirs
it's interesting when they write it it's
typically before they make a big
decision the courage to be free
Florida's blueprint for American Revival
shapeac reportedly told the Santas that
he was getting a lot of pressure away
to wane against the bill stating we get
pressured all the time but this time is
different I haven't seen anything like
this before the parental rights and
education bill which was passed in March
of 2022 prohibits teachers from
discussing sexual orientation or gender
identity in kindergarten through third
grade shape hack expresses opinion to
the bill stating that if it were to be
passed it could be used to unfairly
Target gay lesbian non-binary and
transgender kids and families the
scientists wrote ultimately Bob shape
and Disney cave to the leftist media and
activist pressure impressed a false
narrative uh against the bill which by
the way that leads to the next Story New
York Post Governor de Santa signs Bill
placing Disney District under State
Control this is a February 27th story
just yesterday he assigned a bill that
rebrands Disney self-governed reading
Creek improvement district as the
central Florida tourism oversight
District which will now be under the
state control ending Disney's near
autonomous control over the area the
bill gives the santis the power to
appoint the members of a 5 person
oversight board for the special district
which was previously held by Disney the
center stated that the move will bring
accountability to distance operation in
the district and that it would not lead
to any additional tax burden of
Floridians the move comes after a
month-long feud between the centers and
Disney over the states don't say Gable
law which bars discussions of gender
identity etc etc go ahead Adam thoughts
on the story well I I'm going to give
the Santa's praise and then maybe some
criticism here uh I've been pretty vocal
that I'm definitely more supportive of
him than other candidates that are
potentially running on the right
um
I think everything comes down to Optics
I mean if the the bill was called the
parental rights of Education Bill and
then when it came out to marketing or
backlash against the bill it somehow
turned into the don't say gay bill
that's not the name of the bill and you
know I don't have kids but I I'm pretty
open that I I'm very active in the role
of my nephew and
you know I don't want kindergarteners
learning about gender and identity this
is not anything that is apparent that I
would want my kids even discussing in
kindergarten it's not anything that I
think is inappropriate and I think it's
actually
um spot on by why you would want to do
this but also what what Ron DeSantis and
I think it's worked for him I don't know
if it's going to backfire
he is leading the league and going in
the culture wars you know with with uh
the don't say gay stuff the LGBT stuff
the woke stuff this is where woke goes
to die critical race Theory that's the
Santa's Playbook he's going against the
left and that in that ideology and
that's great here's my concern Pat so
when you read that second story about
placing bills placing uh placing Disney
under State Control
I don't know when I hear the term under
State control that seems very uh
government overreach not free market
approach that Republicans have basically
prided themselves on since pre-regan
days so I'm wondering if that is going
to come under some sort of backlash that
to me is not the free enterprise and
freedom which he has basically made his
name on so I think at the end of the day
he needs to have a sit down with Bob
Iger who's the new acting CEO of Disney
it's no longer the jpac guy and figure
this out because uh once you become on
the national stage and do run for
president uh I don't know if this is
going to be a winning battle to go
against Disney
well this has been coming for a while so
let's step back to something you just
summarized there and let me offer
another perspective
the
the area the Reedy Creek improvement
district Once Upon a Time Disney took
this massive piece of Florida property
and developed it for theme parks and we
all know where it was Disney World and
then Epcot and all the things that are
around there and it managed that area
roads and all this kind of stuff were
managed by Disney it also got tax
benefit
so this what Disney is being told is hey
Florida's going to manage this the same
way we manage the land and the byways
and highways and streets in the rest of
the city and you don't have your
autonomous control over what could
happen in the area and we're going to
take a tax benefit away from you so
basically what they're doing is
every city out there that's ever tried
to attract a manufacturer like Toyota in
Tennessee was given tremendous tax
benefits to build your factory here and
create jobs Mercedes in Alabama and and
and and Disney Once Upon a Time was
given a tax benefit and says come make
Jobs Here Come build you they were
almost their own country that's exactly
right that's the difference and that's
not common with anybody because they
have their own guidelines yeah because
it's very common in the Native American
communities it's huge here in Florida so
there is some uh but Native Americans
that has a reason for it because it's a
way of a reparation the negotiation they
had versus Disney is hey that's what was
similar to what Ron L Ron Hubbard
negotiated Scientology to be a religion
it's the same way Disney negotiated for
their land to be their own countries
making a case to start the religion of
Disney and they already they already
have one so my last Point here to wrap
it up so people can see it but when
Toyota comes to Tennessee it's an
established area when Toyota came to
Tennessee it was an established town
when Mercedes came to Alabama it was an
established location when Disney was
first given this it was a swamp where
they had a plan to build the city and
all the stuff that went with it so now
all those years later DeSantis is saying
hey you know what we're not going to do
this anymore you're not going to be your
own country your own thing we're going
to manage this area the same way we
manage everything else in the State of
Florida but let me ask you because you
bring up a great Point what was the
impetus for him doing this wasn't it
because Disney
and Bob chapac took the lead on these
culture wars that I was speaking about
and this is sort of punishment to say
you know keep talking [__] Disney and
we're gonna see what we're gonna do with
your tax benefits well I would summarize
it I would say you're I believe you're
on the right track with that and I think
it goes like this hey Disney you know
what thanks for nothing thanks for
nothing and you know for 20 years we've
been talking about your special
privilege District here and talking
about changing it guess what dude that
change happens today
so was it a little retaliatory yes but
this has been coming through I think
this is how I see it I totally get what
you're saying I'm about uh debate
discourse let's talk let's uh hash it
out and then give the freedom
uh uh to do what you want to do and you
know let the market decide whether they
want to buy the product or not okay
however here's a question uh say you
have a new employee that works for you
and go five years from now you're
married with two kids okay
and this new ply of yours is working for
you you're helping them your Mentor he
comes to your house okay
first time you let them in your house
your wife makes him a meal and let's
just say your wife is very attractive
and he says oh wow Mary you look great
wow Adam you've got a beautiful wife
good for you okay he's being friendly no
problem all right next time he comes
back he says it again now let's just say
she's wearing a dress and she says oh my
God look at that body of yours you look
beautiful no prom you're like okay
little little too much next time she
comes she says I can't believe how
beautiful your lips are you know and
you're like
okay easy buddy there's a little bit
you're going okay so so Watch What
Happens Next Watch What Happens I don't
like the direction you're going but I'm
going to tell you exactly where I'm
going with this so the next thing at
this point you're kind of like okay this
is this is a first of all I'm letting
you in my house then the next time he
kisses your wife on the cheek but a
little too close Okay like a calm
of the hand is slightly lower okay
and at this point you're sitting there
saying all right bro we gotta have a
conversation okay
so then your kids are with them and he's
playing with your kids and he's getting
a little bit too much out of control the
following time his comments are getting
worse and worse and worse at what point
do you say get the hell out of my house
what the hell are you doing what is the
matter with you you've crossed the line
there is no more respect here's what
Disney's done over the years Disney was
a place where families went to to have
fun no politics no nothing we went to
have fun
gradually they went from saying hey Adam
your kids are beautiful kids thank you
hey kids you don't have to listen to
your mom and dad what they have to say
you're a kid you may be more creative
than them like I'm not going hey kids
how are you you may be gay lesbian or
bisexual listen you've officially
crossed the line Disney and here's what
we have to do you're being put into
timeout this is a form of a punishment
for crossing the line and making it from
a place of entertainment to the kids to
wanting to indoctrinate and groom my
kids no you're arrested Disney here you
go so I'm fully supportive of what he
did I don't know how long this is going
to be staying there this needs to be a
precedent for any other Parks or places
that are being built for kids to realize
don't mess with other people's kids the
moment you do that you've officially
pissed off moms and dads and now you
have a bunch of enemies that are not
supposed part of what you're doing so I
like what he did I think he's shown his
power moves and quite frankly his next
job is going to go from being one state
which he raised 211 million dollars for
his job as a governor which by the way
we didn't say this last time it was a
record no one's ever raised that kind of
money before for governor including uh
uh obviously LA California what's a
bigger number one Meg Whitman was
running but it's a record for what he
did so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign